hey there proflos community my name is
cameron and today's quick tip we are
talking about
motion blur what do i mean when i talk
about motion blur so
typically most of you are going to know
what motion blur is but i've got two
keyframes here i've got a beginning
keyframe and an ending keyframe so that
our
circle goes across the screen here and
it comes to an end right so it
eases out moves quickly here and then
comes to a rest here
and as we can see it's just a straight
up animation there is no motion blur
applied to enable motion blur we have to
click
right here enable motion blur and we
also have to turn motion blur on
for our layer right here and the minute
we do that we can see
now all of a sudden we've got some
interesting real world motion blur
happening here so when we see objects
move in the real world
on film they have motion blur applied so
this is with motion blur
this is without now what i want to talk
to you about really quickly here
is how to adjust your motion blur
settings to
fit whatever style that you are going
for so what we're going to do is we're
going to hit command
k on a mac command k we're going to go
up to composition
settings right here bring open this
window
and under advance we have motion blur
settings right here okay now i've got
mine set to 90
negative 90 16 and 128 if you play
around with these
well specifically these two values right
here
you're going to get some really
interesting results so let's change it
from 90 to 180.
see how much more motion blur we've got
happening here we can also change this
to something like maybe
you know i'm just going up an even
number here so maybe like 270
right there even more motion blur now we
can increase
our samples per frame right here from 16
to say something like
32 let's double them and look at that
just
really nice motion blur happening there
we can also turn it down to something
really low like maybe
four and we get this kind of like onion
skin
type of look happening here so if i
preview this if i click ok and i preview
this right now
you can see here we've got a very
stylized type of motion blur
with only four steps happening just like
so so command
k to open up your composition settings
go to advanced
and right here we can change
our shutter angle to get a different
type of look we can also play around
with things like
shutter phase and adaptive sample limit
but i'm focused on these two numbers
right here today shutter angle 90
sample frames let's go back up to 16
and there we go we've got a really nice
simple but effective motion blur